[Music]
so that's who won the World Series oh
hey there a nostalgia nation it's me
John coming at you again to discuss yet
another ready player one teaser clip
that's right I assume we're about to get
yet another look inside the Oasis and
another look at the very many
recognizable properties therein so join
me also patron today's shout-out is
gonna go to Austin Moore so stay tuned
after the video for your shout out buddy
alright let's do this
[Music]
this is the Oasis it's a place with the
limits of reality are your own
imagination for all the things they can
do but they stay because all the things
they can be you're talking to all of you
now because we're futures being
threatened
[Music]
[Music]
people it lost their lives
control of the pizza
[Music]
dang
[Music]
Lena wait
[Music]
ah
[Music]
are you really
[Music]
[Music]
interesting another slow another slow
somber cover version but instead it's of
the pure imagination song which hey I
mean that that's that's fitting what can
I say about this trailer it looks like a
ready player one trailer for sure I like
that this time around we're getting a
bit more of the themes instead of just
oh look who's here look at this guy in
that guy you know it's nice to actually
get some more of the themes of this
story at least in voiceover format at
this point I just want to see it I'm a
little tired of trailers for this movie
because each one is kind of the same to
me
I get what the stacks look like now I
get a little bit more of what a waste
this is like from this trailer but I
kind of understood I feel like already
um I do like that we get a little bit
more of the glimpses into what the
resistance is doing outside of the Oasis
you see them actually like driving
around and what appears to be real life
and what appear to be the real life
stacks coming down so that's cool that's
something new ish and my man the Iron
Giant gets a whole like featured shot in
this trailer kind of reminded me of the
movie itself which I'm sure is
intentional although Dean's workshop is
nowhere near as state-of-the-art is this
one but you know that's one of my
favorite films of all time so I am
excited to see that and for all you
videogame connoisseurs out there I
caught some of the Spartan warriors from
Halo that's pretty cool and it looks
like maybe that tellurians gonna get to
do a little more than we expected there
are a few different shots and it's
definitely cool to see that riding
through the snow in a hot pursuit of
something I feel like this is gonna
become like Lord of the Rings or
something by the end of it just like a
video game
intellectual property spanning epic
battle movie of some kind and more
spielberg you've got a t-rex in here and
you also got King Kong in here every
time just it just added some more
characters guy gotta love it gotta love
that familiarity train
gotta love familiar things and idea
caught lean away thin this trailer
that's cool and you know
curious about this movie I'm honestly a
little skeptical just because I know how
much you can get by on nostalgia these
days and this movie is like a nostalgic
gasm and coming from page to screen in a
way that's truly memorable is a hard
thing to do in this movie looks
expensive
I am rooting for it but I am also kind
of worried about it just because this is
not a guarantee for me pretty much every
trailer is just a joke
this town's in action and see G&S town
yeah and you know that's cool
I haven't read the book yet so I don't
know exactly what to be excited for
beyond the basic gist of this maybe I'll
listen to it beforehand but you know
what I'm definitely gonna do is I'm
definitely gonna give a patron of the
day shout out to mr. Austin Moore that's
right Austin Moore is a pretty badass
animator doing star wars lego type of
stuff and you know what I want to see us
and more I want to see a complete film
remake of ready player one once it comes
out I want you to remake ready player
one as a lego movie with the lego Iron
Giant with a Lego DeLorean there are so
many kinds of Legos that I feel like the
only other way to do this would be to do
with those because you know like Lego
has the rights to everything and
apparently so does this movie so yeah
dude would you get on that
Austin making demands of you even though
it's your generosity that helps us be
here and as always you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
about to get notified every time review
or a video is out patreon.com slash the
real rejects is where you can find our
exclusive community we got tons of
exclusive content over there music video
reactions TV show reactions full-length
stuff QA a whole bunch of great people
come join us there and also don't forget
to check us out on the stardust app
download link in the description box
follow us first helps us out and as
always guys
Chucho Cheers